oh actually
the most important thing i learned was
how to be interested in almost anything
yeah i mean not to be bored
it hurts it makes me
very sad when i when i see kids talking
to each other and they say
that was boring
and
to me
a person should feel
upset if he would help
if he had to admit that he wasn't able
to find something interesting
so uh uh
you know the skill they
they say i haven't learned how to
how to enjoy life i have to have
somebody entertain me instead of right
that's really interesting it is a skill
uh david foster wallace
i really like
the thing he says about this which is
the key to life is to be unborable
and i do really like you saying that
it's a skill
because i think that's a really good
that's really good advice which is if
you find something boring
that's not
i don't believe it's because
it's boring it's because you haven't
developed you've learned how to how to
find the beauty and how to find the fun
in it
yeah that's a that's a really really
good point
you know sometimes it's
more difficult than others
i had to do this but
i mean during the covet
lots of days when i did when i never saw
another human being but um
but
i i i still find other ways to
it still was a pretty fun time yeah yeah
i i came earlier i came a few minutes
early
today and i
walked around foster city
i didn't want you know i didn't know
what was going on in foster city i saw a
beautiful
beautiful flowers at the nursery at home
depot a few blocks away
life is amazing it's full of amazing
things like this yeah i just sometimes
i'll i'll sit there and just stare at a
tree
nature is beautiful
you